SPEAKER: You can find just
about anything on the internet.
But when you click
a link, how do you
know what's on the other side?
Phishing and malware are
more prevalent than ever
and pose a real threat to
the personal information
of yourself and your users.
You can make sure your users
can quickly identify bad sites
and help protect their
information with Web
Risk from Google Cloud.
Web Risk contains a
fully managed database
of URL threats that
you can scan against
to know if the URL is safe.
Once if it's unsafe, you
can take appropriate action,
such as blocking the content
or letting your users know
they shouldn't proceed.
When you look up a
URL, Google checks
to see if it's in the
database of known unsafe URLs.
This database is constantly
updated by scanning over
1 billion URLs every day.
Using a combination of
rules, machine learning,
and human analysis, URLs
are gathered and scanned
from sources like Google Search.
The Web Risk database is
constantly kept up to date,
so you and your users
can be confident
that the analysis is
reliable and accurate.
So the next time user
generated content is posted,
your users can
feel secure knowing
that you've protected them
against any malicious URLs.
Getting started with the
Web Risk Lookup API is easy.
Once you've enabled the
API, all you need to do
is submit the URL to be checked
against Google's block list.
If there's no result,
the URL is safe.
Otherwise, Google will
return what type of threat
has been detected
and when you'll
want to call the API again to
check if it's still unsafe.
To get started
with a Lookup API,
we'll head over to the console.
From the search at the
top, search for Web
Risk so that we can
enable the API for use
in this Google Cloud project.
Now we can create
a service account
to securely call the API, so
click Credentials and then
Create Credentials.
We'll make a service account
called Web Risk Runner.
Once that's created, we can
download the service account
key to easily make API calls on
behalf of our service account.
Now we can switch
to Cloud Shell,
or you can use a
local environment
with G Cloud already set up.
First, we can set the
application credentials
to point to the
service account key.
Then, all we need to
do is run this command.
This command makes a
request to the Web Risk
API using our service
account credentials.
Here, we're looking for malware
on the URL testsafebrowsing
.appspot.com/s/malware.html,
and the response confirms that
malware has been detected on
the URL as well as an expiration
time so that we could cache the
result locally and know when
to scan this particular URL.
There's more than
just the Lookup API.
If you're looking
for lower latency
or for private
scanning, Web Risk
also offers an offline database
through the Update API.
For even more details, you
can use the Evaluation API
to get a confidence score
and the Submission API
to report suspected URLs.
There's a lot of URLs
out there, so get
started for free with Web Risk
today to protect your users.
Check out the link
to learn more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]